the start of the new school year it is
inching closer as children are enjoying
what's left of summer break school
essentials are already hitting the
shelves of stores at a higher cost
jeremy j ford spoke with parents on what
they plan to do to try and save a little
money
it's time to prepare to send your kids
back to school but with inflation on the
rise there's ways that you can save a
buck people get really discombobulated
when it's everything's last minute which
is why elias salcedo says he saves up
for back to school shopping i buy like
everything in bulk like the school
clothes and then like
their school supplies and then like the
lunch materials but not everyone can
afford that it currently costs between
500 to 850 dollars to send a child to
school making supply drives a cheaper
option it helps young kids in our
community who don't have the resources
or live beyond poverty lines to go back
to school confidence something marquis
jamison who has friends that have
struggled knows all too well really
taking advantage of a lot of the the
resources around us connecting to
people who are graduating from the same
school or other people around you who
might not be using their supplies
anymore thrift stores hand me down just
to take advantage of that and if that
doesn't work michelle ballen suggests
going to their school's counselor
they usually have social workers or
counselors there that are in touch with
local organizations that can help assist
with school supplies
jeremy j ford live local now